during his trip to north carolina the
president encouraged his supporters to
test the system he says
for voting by mail in a way that could
be could be illegal
mail-in voting starts tomorrow in that
state making it the first in the nation
to collect ballots for the november
election
ben tracy reports on the president's new
message
i would go and follow it and go vote
at an airport rally in north carolina
wednesday president trump told his
supporters
that if they vote by mail they should
also then go vote in person
and then if they tabulate it very late
which they shouldn't be doing
they'll see you voted and so it won't
count so send it in early
and then go and vote and if it's not
tabulated you vote
and the vote is going to count you can't
let them take your vote away
in some states you can ask for your
mail-in ballot to be invalidated
but intentionally voting twice is fraud
and a felony in most states
and could lead to chaos at precincts on
election day
the president's message in the critical
swing state of north carolina was no
accident it starts sending out ballots
tomorrow to voters who request them
president trump has been attacking
mail-in voting for months
i don't like this male invalid deal
despite voting that way himself
several times this is playing with fire
this is playing with fire
and now attorney general bill barr is
following the president's lead
sowing doubt over mail-in voting just as
many voters are worried about voting in
person
due to the pandemic but elections that
have been held
with mail have found substantial fraud
and coercion
barr made the unfounded claim wednesday
that mail-in voting leads to widespread
fraud
despite the fact that five u.s states
have used mail-in ballots exclusively
for years
with few problems and millions of
americans vote by mail with absentee
ballots each year
president trump is now directing the
attorney general to drop a list of what
he calls anarchist jurisdictions
last night the white house released a
memo in which president trump directs
his federal agencies
to begin the process of defunding
several u.s cities
that he thinks have allowed lawless
protests including new york
seattle portland and washington d.c
these are all cities run by democrats
the president is trying to basically cut
off any federal funding for those states
that would be under his control gail ben
thank you